the one thing that you do need to pay
attention to with touch on mobile is the
cliq delay touch supporting mobile
browsers usually interpret double
tapping as a zoom to this element
gesture unfortunately this means the
platform delays firing the click event
until it can decide whether the user is
double tapping about a third of a second
chrome has recently checked in some
changes that minimize this behavior but
pretty much all mobile browsers have
this click delay feature to some degree
there are a few ways to fix this problem
and get clicks without a delay you can
set the viewport to be non scalable
either set user scalable to know or set
minimum scale and maximum scale to one
which has the same effect this can cause
accessibility problems though so be
careful jumping to this solution you
need to make sure if you do this that
your site will never need to be zoomed
you can use a fast click library like
the FT labs one that we've linked down
below but you do have to be careful
about how this impacts your scrolling
performance be sure to read the
directions very carefully or finally of
course you can implement touch support
yourself directly if you consume the
touch events you won't have this issue